das ist wirklich ein armer meldung
forschungsteams weltweit entdecken immer
mehr neuartige riesen viren die sich an
der grenze zum leben befinden
normalerweise sind wir ja auf einen wirt
angewiesen um zu existieren sie müssen
also fremde zellen körpern um sich zu
vermehren
doch die mit seriösen riesen wären sind
nicht nur so groß wie bakterien ihr
genom enthält auch überraschender weise
die bauanleitung für die protein
biosynthese nur eine kleinigkeit fehlt
nach dem riesen virus um sich
selbstständig zu vermehren wie ein
echtes lebewesen also herzlich
willkommen bei pixum science fiction bei
uns gibt es täglich faszinierendes
seines videos abonniert den kanal um
nichts zu verpassen herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
vielen dank für diesen spannenden
vorschlag aus eurer community auf
whatsapp den link findet ihr in der
video beschreibung ja sie sind einfach
nur riesig ihr körper ist
durchschnittlich 450 nanometer lang und
daran hängt zudem noch ein 550
nanometern langer und 450 nanometer
dicke schwanz und das macht sie zu den
größten bekannten viren überhaupt die
rede ist von den sogenannten tukan wären
ein forschungsteam aus frankreich hatte
proben aus einem alkalischen salzsee in
brasilien und ebenso aus der tiefsee vor
der brasilianischen atlantikküste
entnommen und dabei diese riesen viren
aufgespürt sie hatten am mögen befallen
die ihnen als wird dienten die analyse
unter dem elektronenmikroskop enttarnte
dann ihre enorme größe und den längsten
schwanz der je bei einem virus
beschrieben wurde so einer der
beteiligten forscher
jonas abram einige wehren erreichten
sogar eine länge von 23 mikrometern
doch nicht nur dass das wirklich
außergewöhnliche an diesem virus typ ist
sein genom denn das enthält die
bauanleitung für den gesamten prozess
der protein biosynthese und das ist
wirklich ein novum in der biologie ein
organismus gilt nur dann als lebewesen
wenn er sich selbst vermehren kann
konkret passiert das durch die
sogenannte protein biosynthese bei der
vereinfacht gesagt in zellen neue
eiweiße gebildet werden bisher war klar
dazu sind höhere organismen aber auch
pilze und bakterien in der lage wären
dagegen
auch in wirtszellen um sich zu vermehren
denn sie selbst besitzen weder die gene
noch die ausstattung um proteine
selbstständig herzustellen und so gelten
viren eben auch nicht als echte
lebewesen bisher
doch diese annahme ist so vielleicht
schon bald komplett überholt den
forschungsteams haben in den vergangenen
jahren schon mehrmals neue viren
entdeckt die sich nicht an dieses schema
halten dazu zählen beispielsweise die
riesen wären namens mega virus klos neue
viren oder pandora virus allesamt sind
genauso groß wie bakterien und ihr
erbgut ist ausgestattet mit viel mehr
gene als man es bislang von viren kannte
konkret enthält die dna der thuban wären
bis zu 1,5 millionen basenpaare und bis
zu 1400 25 gehen die proteine kodieren
damit ist es das viertgrößte genom eines
virus das bislang bekannt ist sie
enthalten die bauanleitung für enzyme
die alle 20 aminosäuren bauen können um
bis zu 70 transporters als unabdingbarer
faktoren für die prozesse der protein
biosynthese und damit ihre
eigenständigen vermehrung das alles ist
auch für die forschungsteams eine große
überraschung denn all das zusammen
gezählt ähneln sie sehr den echten
zellulären organismen nur eine sache
fehlt und das sind die sogenannten
ribosomen diese zellulären gebildet
treiben die protein biosynthese an
fungieren also als katalysator
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler stehen vor einem großen
rätsel denn wie genau sind diese zwitter
aus viren und bakterien entstanden
möglicherweise haben sie sich aus
normalen viren entwickelt die aber mit
der zeit erbstücke aus ihren wirten
übernommen haben eine weitere
möglichkeit wäre aber auch dass ihre
vorgänger cellular waren dann aber ihr
innenleben wieder reduziert haben diese
letzte version erscheint zumindest bei
den tukan wären als wahrscheinlicher
denn um als zell parasit optimal zu
existieren war es eventuell wichtig die
eigene zelle ausstattung auf ein minimum
zu reduzieren so könnten ehemals größere
organismen teile der protein biosynthese
und auch der energieversorgung gekappt
haben 30 prozent der super virus
genommen es ist jedenfalls noch
unerforscht es ist also mit weiteren
überraschungen zu rechnen wenn er kein
video dazu in zukunft verpassen wollt
dann abonniere auch auf
denn auch da gibt es immer mehr
videopremieren dafür einfach hier
draufklicken und darunter geht es weiter
mit rock made by sun and light solution
zu global hunger
bis bald hoffentlich auf dem englischen
kanal also darauf klicken für das video
zu tun
stay tuned